so i've been watching this documentary  series wild galapagos on curiosity  stream and it's all about the galapagos  islands which are absolutely fascinating  and because they're so isolated i didn't  realize that we can learn a crazy amount  about how plants and animals moved  around on planet earth by looking at  what is on the galapagos island and what  isn't  i would encourage you to check this out  if you're interested in science if  you're interested in animals super super  fascinating like i said i watched it on  curiosity stream curiosity stream is the  best streaming service for documentaries  much better selection than the other  streaming services and it's really cheap  and you can watch it on all your devices  it's 15 bucks for the entire year  not a month a year it's like a buck 25 a  month you can use the link in the  description or go to curiositystream.com  david to check it out